hey guys what's up I'm Alana and today i
am playing more of alien isolation
pretty nervous where i left off was
absolutely hectic and i'm actually
playing on my new TV now you guys not
going to say this looks pretty good this
TV is 65 inches so you're probably gonna
see my eyes like dotting around a little
more because this thing's massive also i
heard that is what she said so look for
a little ok ok we could all right so
alien is just appeared but the biggest
concern right now is synthetics ok he's
not gonna turn around oh god oh no he's
not all right Oh already are you serious
oh I should just let him kill me I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna live through this
I'm really not gonna live through this
at all oh my god what did he even come
from you must been in that room if I
just I just jump walk in here yes is he
gonna rip it open and kill me or is he
yeah that's what's gonna happen isn't it
huh ok we're good no fine fine that's
nothing
no [ __ ] your assistance what if he can
hear that Oh something to the left of me
oh no no no no no no no no no no there's
not does not okay oh I mean it seems
like he's walking away yeah okay let's
do it let's just do it yeah oh oh
there's no what I wanted was it me that
open that oh I hope it was me that open
that should have been should've been
should have been alright that was
actually some pretty bad I I though to
be honest I mean I mean he terrified me
and I have no idea where it came from
something just vibrated what was that oh
oh so he's gonna come back down here
isn't he surely at some point I'm not
not gonna have like a lot of time to
just wait here when the other guy go
okay yeah yeah that's good this looks
good oh man just don't turn around hey
don't turn around so that would be
really not fun for anyone nobody wants
that don't even think about it nobody
wants that will be the lamest all right
seems okay in here yep hurricane iya
alright man
so I'm pretty sure at the moment what
I'm trying to do is get to medicine or
something somebody needs needs medicine
so i'm trying to get to them to help
them out but all of the synthetics are
on overdrive which is super fun just
kidding it's actually not fun at all I
know if I want to sign in I don't know
if I want to waste that time you know I
think it's worth it ah what is this oh
oh oh it's an explosion sorry friend I'm
accessing this rewire yeah I still have
not found a use for these but uh I mean
surely there is a useful them I just
haven't encountered one all right we're
okay in here so let's pick up that yes
hello ID tag can we pick up that no all
right what are we doing what are we
doing we're supposed to be going not in
here apparently through their out that
way it's really [ __ ] hot don't know
why I say that like I'm surprised this
entire game is horribly hard but
okay probably be able to get out the
store anyway am i like did this even
really accomplish much where am i right
now Oh what one here we go yeah I have
to go that way son of a [ __ ] I mean
there's no one really nearby but you
know some strange reason I don't follow
oh he's he's headed up here oh my god
come any closer
are you walking away you walking away
should walk away you came to the wrong
corridor [ __ ] come on in to two
of them 11 left why I know to what if
it's alien oh I would be I would at this
point be way happier if it was alien
rather than it being a [ __ ] synthetic
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I can only go
this way right so if that one walks back
here the one that's facing the other way
this can be so hard ok I don't think he
doesn't come this far like oh my god
that seem right there he's not he can't
see me right no he can't see me it's the
one on this side that's a bit of a
problem i wonder if they can hear this
well he's right there so we gotta wait
for him to back off before I can I don't
worry yes I could just see you make
things a lot easier uh
I swear I just saw his head am I going
crazy he's right then or he's totally
right there hey oh oh my god oh my god
oh my god no no no no no no no no no
please don't see me no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no oh my god
[ __ ] should I run where would I run to
the whole way am I gonna make that I'm
probably not gonna make that you guys oh
but he just they know I'm there they
know I'm day he saw me I'm gonna try and
run I'm gonna try and do it is it him
who sees me I mean da he's looking right
at me let's [ __ ] run let's run run oh
my god wow your eyes up did I muscle
press a robe on and I'm dead and I'm
dead and i'm [ __ ] dead